e Herkese merhabalar ben Milli Boksör bu
sana attığım evi
bu hoş gelmiştir kalmadığından daha
farklı bir şekilde sesini olacağım bir
gün üzere kendimden dolayı size bu
sahneden yüzüne bakarak kim yapmak vardı
ama nasıl kıymış Açıkçası ben de çok
isterdim sizinle sohbet edip yüz yüze
tanışmaya Ama gerçekten pandemi den
dolayı birazcık
Bu sıkıntılar ve duymuş herkes görüyor
Ve herkes içeriyor Burası beni
çalıştığım yer Trabzon Türkiye olimpiyat
hazırlık Merkezi Salonu belde gecem
gündüzüm orada geçiyor istiyorsun
buradan seslenmek istedim ki beni az çok
anlayabilirsiniz diye Çünkü burası böyle
ikinci el hat Pardon bir evin ikinci
evin annemin yanı
bu birazcık kendi hikayemden başladık
biraz kendimi tanıtmak istiyorum ben bu
sefer Sürmeli 22 yaşında yaklaşık 12
senedir 12 şehri boks sporuyla
uğraşıyorum
da kalemli bir futbolsever oldum 5
Avrupa şampiyonu ve 3 dünya şampiyonluğu
var o zıt boksa başlama ama böyle
evresini anlatmak istiyorum biraz
karışık ama ya En kısa yoldan Anlatmaya
çalışacağım Biz babamın işleri bile bu
suda oturuyordum ama şeyleriyle
trabzanın şimdi Trabzon'a taşındı ve ben
Bursa'da Futbol Kulübü neydi ve çok
futbol oynamak istiyorum Trabzon'a
geldiğimde ama Trabzon'da böyle
profesyonel andan Futbol Kulübü yoktu
bir bayram vesilesiyle
bir antrenörün orada karşılaştık Aslında
daha önceden konuşuyordum kendisiyle
daha üstüme teyzemi de şunu oluruz
zamanda şu an hala ona çalışıyorum Konuş
şimdi anneme demiş ki ben bilmiyorum
tabi Burada değilmiş yapıyoruz Trabzon'a
gelirse Bunu ben boşalacağım değilmiş
Çünkü çok hareketli çok önü tuttuğunu
koparan böyle çok yani kışlı bir
kişiliğin var karakterim var Onu boksa
özdeştir ince de çok güzel şeyler
çıkıyor ortaya Gerçekten böyle Aslında
çocukluk anılarını anlatmak gerekirse
böyle bir şiddetle gider misin
bisikletten büyük aldığım kaldırmak
dalmışım o konuyu atlamışım bisiklet
atar mısın topla oynar mısın böyle Serap
çok hatırlıyorum hayalmi ama
anlattıklarım böyle çok yaramazmışım
aynı zaman Aslı birazcık da
bu maçları başladım Çünkü yaşım o zaman
2013 senesinde ilk resmi müsabakalar
sıkıldım gerçekten benim benim hayal
ettiğim bir seni de çok güzel
çalışıyordum 2013 senesinde milli takım
kapıları bana o zaman açıldı Hala da
milli takım dayım yaklaşık 7-8 sene oldu
milli takımda yoruluyorum ve ülkenin
bayrağını eşiklerde dağların durmak için
savaşıyorum kanımızın Son damlasına
kadar gerçekten
Ama bu zorlu süreçte ne kadar siz
olursanız oldu sadece sizin arkanızda
sizi destekleyen birinin olmazsa
gerçekten bu kadın yani
ya bu kadar başarılı olamaz
O benim İstiklal gerçekten çok insan var
onların en başında ise iki şey aramıyor
o da annemi annemi buradan Elif
bırakıyorum ve selamlarımı söylüyorum
annem benim en özel en özel
değişikliklerine sitelerinden biriyle
babam İlk başlarda bana gerçekten böyle
yani boks olmaz yani yapma girilen diyor
ama ben hiçbir zaman pes etmedim kendine
böyle çıktım ve yapacağım dedim yani
ne olacak dedim ben gideceğim dedim
gerçekten de yaptım babam Ne şifre Medi
beni başlarda sadece Annem bir şey dedi
ama en sonunda O da başarılar geldikçe
böyle ne kadar güzel bir spor olduğunu
gördükçe ve o da mı desteklemeye çalıştı
Ama gerçekten birçok Zorlu yollardan
geçip maşalı Hazırlanıyoruz bir maça ya
sorma girmemiz bizim 67 ayağımızı
buluyor Ve sabah-akşam Akşama
yapıyorsunuz Haftanın altı günü
antrenman yapıyoruz salçalar hiçbir
gününüz boş oluyor çok büyük fedakarlık
ten veriyoruz gerçekten çok büyük
zorluklar da veriyoruz Yani benim
Ben ailemi ki alem benim takımı Çünkü
ailemden çok onlarla görüşüyorum alemde
çok onlar ne zaman geçiriyorum yani
işinizde sevmeniz lazım Çünkü gerçekten
dediğim gibi çok zorluklar çekiyoruz Ben
valizimi alıp kullanmış çıkıyorum
gerçekten Baksana bir şekilde soru
kızsın beş gün yok yani eve geliyorum
Annem var bir kokunu içine çekiyor Diyor
ki yani kızım Neredesin Özledim seni
falan diyor ama artık alıştılar Gerçek
Hiç öyle yapmıyor gerçekten
Ama dediğim gibi çok zorluk bir süreç
yaşıyoruz olimpiyatlarda zaten çok zorlu
geçecek Tamam abi
Ama ben her şeyi güzel olacağına
inanıyorum
var ama
Ama şöyle bir şey var
ama ben
bir Türk Kadınıyım ve hiçbir zaman poşet
verdim çok zorluklar geçirdim gerçekten
sakatlandım çevrenin baskısı Bana karşı
çok oluyorum ha bırakma adresine geldim
ama hiçbir zaman ama hiçbir zaman bir
şey etmedim düştüm kalktım yay kalktı mı
var daha beter düştük daha güçlü kalktı
bir daha düştüm daha daha düşük attım şu
an Sizin karşınızda oluyorsam o düştüğüm
yerden test etmediğim için çok iyi böyle
dağılmış sana kalktım birşeysin Kaçmaz
oturuyorum
O benim yeteneklerimi keşfettiler
keşfettim o yüzden bu sporu devam ettim
Herkesin bir şeye ama ya küçük bir şey
mutlu olsa yeteneği vardır Her şey
herkesin bir şey getireyim vardır Onu
nasıl size keşfetmek herhalde onu
devamlılığı önemli bu
Ya ben kendimi bu alanda geliştirdiğim
için bir yeteneklerini birleştirdim
hışımla karakterini birleştirdim için bu
alanda Bu yüzden başarılı oldum sizde
Gerçekten bunu ise Yani bu istediği bu
hayatta başarılı olabilmeniz için bir
şey sürekli ve çok istemiyoruz lazım
gerçekten ben Bütün benliğinle istediğim
için belki de bu kadar nasil başarılı
olabildim kadar şampiyonlukları
kazanabil
E tabii ki ok sporla uğraşıyorum çevre
baskısı dedim çok var üzerinde size bir
anımı anlatmak istiyorum çevre baskısını
başarıyla nasıl değiştire bildiğimi
anlatmak istiyorum geçen bu Trabzon
Meydanı var oradan yürüyorum böyle bir
tane doğum dolmuştaki ağabey sıfır abi
bana ver bana dünya bu eşyalarımı
ya helal başkasına çalıyordu aldanıyorum
her girmeyeceğim veriyorum bu ya sana
soruyorum sen dedi Ben de herhalde dedim
gerekiyor şöyle yapmış biliyor musun
sana aynı hareketi yap Ne olursun sonra
dedi işte bu dedi ben seni takip
ediyorum dedi sen dedi kız çocuklarını
ilham ilham kaynağı herhangi bir böyle o
kadar mutlu oldum ki Yani o tüm çok
işlerimin tüm çok kötü çöktüğünde ki
acıların hepsini unuttum da Düşünsenize
Yani bir kişi ise böyle sesle ne biliyor
düşünce ne kadar değiştirme bakar
mısınız sadece başarılı olduğunda
İnsanların düşünce yapısını çok
değiştirdim inanıyorum yani kız
çocuklarına özellikle çocuklarına ilham
olabileceğini düşünüyorum Bu çok güzel
ve önemli bir şeyler önce dediğim gibi
bir zamanlar
Ama babam da beni Destek demiyordu Ama
şu anda Gerçekten herkes benim destekçim
arkamda bu kadınlarına
bu Türk kız çocuklarına söylemek
istediğim tek düşünüyorlar Hiçbir zaman
hiçbir zaman bu çekmiş üstünüze daha
inançlı daha güçlü daha böyle içten bir
şekilde kalkar
Ya ben her seferinde böyle yaptığımda
gerçekten kazandım Şimdi de de manevi
duyguları yaşamak istiyorsanız Türk
bayrağı en yukarıda ve desteklemek
istiyorsanız lütfen ama lütfen Ben
hiçbir zaman Pes etmeyin pes etmezseniz
sizde kazanacaksınız bu ülkede kazanacak
herkes kazanacak bak yumruklarımı Her
seferinde Türk bayrağını için atıyorum
şu kız çocuklarımızı çocuklar için
atıyorum tüm kadınlarımızın için
atıyorum bak Kısacası ülkem için hep
savaşıyorum ve savaşmaya devam edeceğim
kanımın Son damlasına kadar ben ben
ülkemizin en iyi şekilde
ve gelişmesini umuyorum yani
diyeceklerim bu kadar Herkese iyi günler
diliyorum Ben herkese buradan öp